I was officially diagnosed with generalized
anxiety disorder at the age of 24 when I finally
disclosed the symptoms I was experiencing
with my doctor. But I knew I always struggled
with it.
For any of you who're out there who experience an anxiety disorder, I know how scary and threatening
it can be; when your breath shortens, your
heart races and your throat tightens.
For some of you, especially those of you who
have panic attacks, it might feel like you're
about to die.
And the worst part about anxiety is that you
never know when it's going to rise again or
worsen; it's invisible, quiet and unpredictable.
We don't get warnings ahead of time, not like
flashing ambulance lights to let us know there's
an emergency with a blare of a sound alarm.
Often it will sneak up on us and breathe negative
thoughts into our headspace.
Ever since I started meditating more and shifting
my self-talk in a better direction, my anxiety
no longer has as much control over my life
as it used too.
But sometimes all it takes is one unfortunate
event to get my heart racing.
For the most part, my childhood was cloaked
in chaos.
Every day it felt like I was walking on eggshells,
I never knew where the next bomb was going
to set off.
I became fearful of many things; death, being
yelled at, eating in front of others, socializing
and not being good enough.
The list goes on but I don't want to bore
you.
My experience with anxiety isn't necessarily
a fairy tale. I still have a long way to go
and I'm not sure if they'll be a happy ending,
but I'm curious enough to find out and keep
going.
It's funny, my relationship with the unknown
used to be a cumulus [sp] one; I would
often get thrown into unpleasant situations
one after the other.
And if I felt like I wasn't performing well,
I was quick to blame myself, but never the
person who had a choice in guiding me in a
healthier fashion.
Nowadays however as I'm navigating a streets
of adulthood, I'm beginning to welcome change
with open arms.
I'm not telling you the water work will stop,
and that there won't be days where you won't
feel like getting out of bed because this
still very much exist for me.
But I can say with confidence, there is so
much for me to live for.
My boyfriend the Cat likes crawling up on the
couch with me.
I've yet to experience and try thousands of
recipes on my list.
And I know there are people my life who care
about me and want me to succeed.
Instead of playing the victim and asking myself
why anxiety chose to haunt me, I stopped feeling
sorry for myself.
Yes, I recognized that if they didn't have
anxiety, maybe my high school years wont have
been as traumatizing for me, and maybe I would
have developed relationships with people I
would want to talk to, but was too afraid
to approach.
But looking back with regrets isn't something
that will propel me forward.
Instead, that's like giving into anxiety and
saying; OK, you win.
You can continue controlling my life.
I know these things are always easier said
than done.
Believe me, I was not able to achieve this
overnight and there are things I still need
to work on.
But anything that's worth having in life is
always worth the effort.
Anxiety is an ongoing battle for me, but it's
no longer threat to me.
Have a personal story you want to share about
experience with anxiety or mental health problem?
Email them to editorial@Psych2Go.net.
Or make a video about it and tag #anxiety,
#depression, #Psych2Go.
We will watch it.
Your story might just get animated and get
paid.
Thanks for watching!